wenn du sie nicht das erste mal web
video ist dass ihr schaut seit ihr
wahrscheinlich freunde der wissenschaft
oder wie man hierzu canale sagt freunde
der sonne ihr verlasst euch nicht so
gerne auf persönliche meinungen ihr
verlasst euch auf daten und zahlen aber
jetzt komme ich und sage euch dass man
sich auch gar nichts verlassen kann
neben ernst zahlen grafen statistiken
können total irre führend sein man kann
statistiken unbewusst missversteht nicht
einsetzen oder auch ganz bewusst damit
manipulieren was steht zum beispiel
dahinter wenn ein wimpern sehr um 14
prozent mehr wachstum verspricht wenn
eine anti aging creme 43 prozent freie
radikale reduziert und was genau heißt
es wenn drei stück becken pro tag das
darmkrebsrisiko um 20 prozent erhöhen
sobald man irgendwo eine zahl sieht
denkt man sich okay damit ist jetzt
alles klar
aber oft ist gar nichts klar es sei denn
man kennt sich ein bisschen mit
statistik aus also holt euch ein tee
macht es sich gemütlich hier steigen
durch übrigens freunde der sonne ihr
habt euch dieses video gewünscht unserem
video über die kita und schule öffnungen
hatte ich euch gefragt ob er ein ganzes
video zu statistik sehen wollt und eine
überwältigende mehrheit von euch hat
gesagt ein bisschen statistik da sage
ich nicht nein sagen kann ich euch die
ergebnisse der umfrage nicht zeigen weil
ich damals kein screenshot gemacht habe
und youtube die umfragen inzwischen
abgeschafft hat rest in peace umfragen
ich habe euch geliebt das heißt
vielleicht liege ich ja und ihr wolltet
gar nicht über statistik ablehnen
was mich zu einer wichtigen anmerkung
führt nämlich es geht in diesem video
nicht um gefälschte zahlen oder
statistiken
nein es geht um ganz korrekte zahlen die
aber durch eine missverständliche
darstellung völlig falsche rückschlüsse
ziehen lassen und um sich davor zu
schützen hilft nur herzlich willkommen
dazu wir haben uns drei alltags
nützliche basics rausgesucht fangen wir
an mit der streuung mit streuung
weidmann dass die tatsächlichen
einzelwerte um den mittelwert herum
verteilt also verstreut sind und wenn
man diese streuung bei der darstellung
der daten weglässt wären zahlen schnell
irreführend nehmen wir mal dieses
beispiel aus der kosmetik werbung
das ist eines dieser wimpern serien die
das eigene wimpern wachstum ankurbeln
sollen und hier wurde offenbar ein
experiment gemacht bei dem die
anwenderinnen am ende 14 21 prozent mehr
wimpern wachstum hatten was auch immer
mehr wimpern wachstum heißt dazu kommen
wir auch später noch aber nehmen wir
zunächst erst mal an dass zumindest die
zahl 14,21 prozent so stimmt oder ihr
ein experiment so eine anti aging creme
ein full fichtes 3d hautmodell
testverfahren wohl hier durchgeführt was
auch immer das ist aber klingt seien sie
die sonnenbrand zellen wurde um 40
prozent freie radikale um 43 prozent
reduziert sehen wir mal davon ab dass
nicht glas was mit sonnenbrand zellen
gemeint ist und nehmen wir auch hier
zumindest mal an dass diese zahlen an
sich stimmen also dass man das genauso
gemessen hat selbst dann sind diese
grafen ziemlich nichtssagend warum das
erklärt sich gleich von selbst wir
müssen freue aber die streuung erstmal
bisschen genauer verstehen beispiel
nehmen wir das fiktive videospiel super
mario
jetzt stellt man fest dass bei super
mario männer im schnitt 14 millionen 605
punkte erzielen frauen dafür 14
millionen 6 und 8 6 punkte das heißt
frauen erzielen im schnitt 1 punkt mehr
als männer
das klingt ja nach einem bedeutungslos
klein unterschied ich würde ja nicht
davon ausgehen deswegen einen punkt bei
einer größenordnung von 14 millionen
frauen wirklich besser in super mario
sind als
ja richtig das ist dass bei diesem
fiktiven beispiel sagen wir auf platte
ticks gibt es aliens und nicht nur das
es gibt männliche und weibliche aliens
die männlichen aliens sind im schnitt
179 groß und die weiblichen aliens im
schnitt einen meter 66 da sind die alien
männer also im schnitt 13 cm größer als
die allen frauen in diesem beispiel sind
diese 13 zentimeter ja ein nennenswerter
unterschied das geht hier nicht um 1 von
14 millionen sondern um 13 von 179 bzw
166 eine super marios also diese ein
punkt unterschiedlich nennenswert bei
den aliens sind es diese 13 cm schon
richtig falsch also genau genommen
können wie diese unterschiede nur
bewerten denn wie die größe der streuung
kennen und diese infos sehr bisher gut
bei super mario ist es tatsächlich nur
plausibel davon auszugehen dass die
punktestände im größenbereich von 14
millionen eben tausende oder
zehntausende bereich schwanken also
streuen aber genaugenommen kennen wir
super mario ja gar nicht und theoretisch
ist es möglich dass die punktestände gar
nicht so stark streuen zum beispiel weil
man in level 1 14 millionen 600 punkte
bekommt quasi als willkommensgeschenk
und danach nur noch ein punkt pro level
ist ein komisches spiel design aber ich
habe es mir nicht ausgedacht
das würde jedenfalls bedeuten dass die
streuung so klein ist dass frauen
möglicherweise doch besser in super
mario sind damit nicht nur eins klar
machen dass einst im vergleich zu 14
millionen 605 so klein ist ist gar nicht
der springende punkt sondern es ist die
streuung auf die es hier ankommt noch
klarer wird dass bei den aliens denn
wisst ihr was den männer- und allen
frauen auf plastik sind im durchschnitt
zufälligerweise genau so groß wie die
männer und frauen auf diesem planeten
beziehungsweise in deutschland für uns
können wir die streuung ganz gut aus
unserem alltag einschätzen also ich will
mit meinen 158 eher am unteren ende der
frauen scala am oberen ende werder zum
beispiel die basketballerin zattoo
saberi mit 193 kurzer zwischenstopp ich
sitze gerade im schnitt und
festgestellt dass sie eventuell auch 189
bzw 187 groß ist deshalb ist groß so
viel steht fest aber ja so viel zum
thema streuung ok weiter geht's aber die
meisten frauen sind zwischen 160 und 170
aber auf platte dix sieht das ganz
anders aus hier sind alien frauen
zwischen 50 cm und drei meter noch was
groß und innerhalb dieser spanne auch
recht normal verteilt und bei den
älteren männern sieht es ganz ähnlich
aus sondern nur die mittelwerte
betrachtet dann erscheint die situation
auf der erde und auch platte ticks genau
gleich aber wenn man die streuung als
fehler balten einträgt dann sieht das so
aus die streuung innerhalb der alien
frauen und innerhalb der alien nenner
ist jeweils viel größer als der
unterschied der beiden mittelwert und
ihr seht eigentlich direkt dass der
durchschnittliche größenunterschied
zwischen alien männern und alien frauen
in der praxis also im alltag von planet
iks sicher eine viel unbedeutende rolle
spielt als auf der erde und nicht nur in
der praxis ist sie streuen bedeuten
sondern auch um zu bewerten wie
aussagekräftig bestimmte daten sind von
der streuen hängt auch ab wie groß meine
stichprobe sein muss bei der kleinen
streuung kann meine stichprobe auch
klein sollen also im extremfall wenn sie
gar keine streuung hätten also sagen wir
auf platte ticks wären alle l männer
genau gleich groß und alle elliott
frauen während genau gleich groß da
würde er eine stichprobe von jeweils 1
reichen um repräsentativ für plane ticks
zu sein
aber je größer die streuung desto größer
muss auch die stichprobe seien für eine
repräsentative messung wenn ich jetzt
beim gegen von serum im kleingedruckten
lese dass die testgruppe aus 25
anwenderinnen bestand und gerade mal
fünf das placebo serum bekam lieber
sehen wir das mal großzügigerweise und
bleiben bei den 25 und würden jetzt
viele direkt schon denken was für ein
quatsch 25 ist er viel zu wenig aber
auch nur 25 probanden können
aussagekräftige ergebnisse liefern oder
zumindest interessante hinweise wenn die
streuung entsprechend klein ist nur über
die streuung erfahren wir hier nichts
und bei der anti aging creme erfahren
wir weder etwas über die streuung noch
über die proben größe in der
wissenschaft dürfte man die streuung nie
weg lassen sie spielt auch bei der
statistischen auswertung der daten
eine große rolle je größer die streuung
ist desto schwieriger ist es
festzustellen ob ein unterschied ihr nur
zufällig oder tatsächlich echt ist so
passiert es zum beispiel nicht selten
dass sein testen eines neuen medikaments
zwischen der testgruppe und der
placebogruppe zwar ein unterschied
gefunden wird der sich aber nach der
statistischen auswertung eines nicht
statistisch signifikant herausstellt
also wahrscheinlich er nur zufällig ist
ohnehin ist es höchst unwahrscheinlich
dass man bei einer testreihe
placebogruppe genau demselben wert misst
sei es bei einem neuen medikament oder
meinem wimpern serum oder eine anti
aging also die mittelwerte alleine sagen
also wenig aus die frage ist doch ob das
zufällig ist oder nicht und so wie das
hier dargestellt ist könnten die 14
prozent wachstum einfach im rahmen der
zufälligen schwankungen seien genauso
diese beiden grafen ohne viel arbeiten
sagt mir das gar nichts beim rhein
bleibt aber der eindruck zurück dass
hier wissenschaftliche experimente
durchgeführt wurden mit scheinbarem
erfolg und das meine ich damit dass man
zahlen noch nicht mal fashion muss um
zahlen zu schönen und übrigens haben wir
uns auch gefragt was eigentlich diese
linien hier bedeuten sollen zumal auch
die achsen gar nicht beschriftet sind
aber ich vermute das soll einfach nur
wissenschaftlich aussehen und es gibt
auch noch mehr probleme mit dem wimpern
serum aber dazu später mehr aber wenn im
alltag schon so viel mit durchschnitten
und mittelwerten hantieren dann sollten
wir die wenigstens richtig wir stehen
damit kommen wir zu punkt 2 der median
90 prozent der befragten halten sich für
bessere autofahrer als der durchschnitt
so was in der art kommt tatsächlich raus
wenn man leute befragt und hat mit der
sogenannten elisa superiore di zu tun
also dem phänomen dass man sich selbst
gerne überschätzt
aber darum geht es hier nicht sondern um
folgendes rechnerisch ist es durchaus
möglich dass 90 prozent besser sind als
der durchschnitt
schauen wir uns das mal genauer unter
durchschnitt verstehen wie in der regel
folgendes wenn wir die
durchschnittsgröße von neuen leuten
bestimmen möchten dann müssen wir jeden
und teilen die summe durch 9
das ist der durchschnitt wie wir ihn
kennen und lieben beziehungsweise
genauer gesagt das arithmetische mittel
allerdings ist dieses arithmetische
mittel manchmal ein bisschen doof und es
gibt eine andere art von durch die
manchmal besser sein kann und zwar indem
die selben leute und stellen sie da
auch auf wie die orgelpfeifen und
anstatt jeden einzelnen zu messen messen
wir nur die größe der person in der
mitte bzw wenn es mir gerade zahl ist
dann nimmt man den mittelwert aus das
athletische mittel zwischen den beiden
mittel diese art von durchschnitt oder
mittelwerten nennt sich medial wenn
jetzt das arithmetische mittel und der
median nah beieinander liegen ist es im
alltag eigentlich egal welches maß man
angibt aber jetzt tauschen wir mal einen
der neun leute gegen robert j lo aus den
größten menschen der welt zwei meter 72
war groß dann verzehrte ja den steht
also das arithmetische mittel nach oben
damit ideal allerdings verändert sich
gar nicht denn mit janis also weniger
empfindlich gegenüber ausreißern bei
ungleich verteilen ist der median der
bessere mittelwert als unser 08 15
arithmetisches mittel zb bei gehältern
wenn wir an das durchschnittsgehalt der
deutschen denken haben wir meistens
nicht auf dem schirm dass die verteilung
so aussieht es gibt also einen ziemlich
langen schwanz an wenigen hoch verdient
wenn jetzt zum beispiel wenige
milliardäre noch reicher werden dann
verzerrt dass das arithmetische mittel
nach oben der median bald aber gleich
unter die meisten von uns keine
milliardäre sind ist der median für uns
viel relevanter ähnlich ist es bei
hauspreisen wo auch wenige aber dafür
exorbitant teure luxusvillen das
arithmetische mittel hochziehen den
median aber nicht kommen wir zurück zu
dem autofahrer beispiel wie können jetzt
theoretisch 90 prozent der autofahrer
besser sein als der durchschnitt naja
wenn wir jetzt autofahren irgendwie
bewerten könnten zb mit noten dann
müssen wir zur folge szenario vorstellen
in dem die meisten autofahrer wird zwei
haben oder 2 - und es gibt nur ganz
wenige autofahrer die grottenschlecht
sind oder glatte sechs haben dann ziehen
die wenigen den durchschnitt runter auf
2,4 aber 90 prozent der autofahrer sind
dann mit ihrer zwei - oder besser besser
als der durchschnitts oder die meisten
menschen haben überdurchschnittlich
viele ohren denn wenn sich auch nur ein
vincent van gogh ein ohr abschneidet
zieht er damit den durchschnitt der
ohren zahl aller menschen auf leicht
unter 2 und damit bin ich mit meinen
vollen zwei ohren überdurchschnittlich
hier verstehen das prinzip das heißt war
so ein autofahrer umfrage interessiert
uns eigentlich wie schätzen sich die
menschen im bezug auf dem median 1 aber
selbst wenn man die frage so formuliert
nämlich gehören sie zu der besseren
hälfte der autofahrer konnten wir uns
ähnliches ergebnis raus also auf die
selbstüberschätzung von menschen ist
verlassen jetzt noch ein letzter oft bis
verstandener punkt absolutes und
relatives risiko ihren bericht der
britischen bbc von letztem jahr
wer am tag statt einem drei streifen
bacon ist hat ein um 20 prozent erhöhtes
darmkrebsrisiko
und obwohl diese zahlen stimmen wurden
die medienberichte der entsprechenden
studie im british medical journal scharf
kritisiert den auch hier fielen wieder
informationen die diese zahlen
missverständlich machen unter 10.000
briten die normal bacon essen also in
diesem fall ein stück pro tag gibt es 40
fälle von darmkrebs
das heißt bei normal verhalten beträgt
das individuelle risiko an darmkrebs zu
erkranken
0,4 prozent bei den viel fleisch essen
die jetzt zum beispiel drei
streifenwagen pro tag essen gibt es
unter 10.000 briten 48 filme die
relative erhöhung von 40 auf 48 sind
also tatsächlich 20 prozent mehr aber
das absolute risiko für jeden einzelnen
hat sich dabei lediglich von 0,4 auf
0,48 prozent erhöht aber die schlagzeile
drei stück banken erhöhen das
darmkrebsrisiko von 0,4 prozent auf 0,48
prozent
das ist jetzt einfach nicht so
erwähnenswert deswegen lassen sich
selbst angesehene medienhäuser wie die
bbc oder manchmal sogar forscher dazu
hinreißen
nur das relative risiko zu nennen jetzt
kommen wir noch mal kurz auf den wimpern
graf zurück ich finde es ja sehr
verdächtig dass hier 14 mehr wimpern
wachstum steht und nicht etwa 14 längere
wimpern oder 14% dichtere wimper das
könnte nämlich auch so was heißen wie
wenn jetzt oder sehr um die wimpern den
bestimmten zeitraum ein millimeter
wachsen mit serum aber 14 prozent mehr
das heißt 114 millimeter dann ist es ja
in bezug auf die gesamtmenge recht
überschaubar und ich würd mir überlegt
ob ich da für mein geld ausgeben genauso
ist es für potenzielle beeke liebhaber
für den alltag relevant da das absolute
risiko zu kennen also da muss man sich
fragen bin ich dazu bereit zwei stück
mehr zu essen wenn dafür das
darmkrebsrisiko von 0,4 auf 0,48 prozent
steigt wobei ich noch gerne dazu sagen
würde dass gerade bei gesundheitsfragen
auch sehr kleine absolute prozentsätze
wie so ohne weiteres verworfen werden
sollten denn 0,08 prozent von 80
millionen deutschen sind immerhin 64.000
darmkrebs fälle die man verhindern
könnte durch etwas so vermeidbares wie
statt drei stück bacon nur noch ein
stück bacon pro tag zu essen also wenn
das wirklich so stimmt dann wäre das ja
super ihr seht zahlen sind nicht gleich
zahlen
man braucht immer kontext und ein
bisschen statistisches grundverständnis
und ich hoffe wir konnten euch da ein
bisschen behilflich sein mit diesem
video das war natürlich kein
vollständiger statistik crashkurs aber
es waren jetzt drei basics die meiner
meinung nach im alter ganz gut
einzusetzen sind und wenn man das einmal
auf dem schirm hat sieht man diese dinge
überall und vielleicht sind ja jetzt
schon spontan beispiele eingefallen wenn
ja schreibt sie gerne in die kommentare
eigentlich wollten wir in diesem video
auch noch die statistik hinter der
sensitivität und spezifität von krone
antikörper test machen also was heißt es
eigentlich wenn ein test 99% spezifisch
ist aber dann dachte ich ist es cooler
dazu ein ganzes video zu machen das
kommt dann als nächstes also an wir über
antikörpertest eben mit statistisch im
fokus wenn ihr dazu fragen vorab
schreibt die gerne jetzt in die
kommentare mit dem hashtag antikörper
ihr verlinkt ich nach unserer video zu
der frage ist ein bisschen alkohol nicht
doch gesund der spielstatistik nämlich
auch eine rolle und schaut doch mal bei
viel lauter vorbei in seinem neuesten
video 1 gegen rassismus bin ich auch
dabei wir sehen uns in zwei wochen und
bis dahin bleibt sicher